one of the great things about this
series of episodes is you get to play
you get to play someone who's got some
darkness to them you can get some menace
and you've got your you know more or
less a criminal boss a guy that's you
know running things and you've you've
come up the hard way and you're very
good at being menacing you're very good
at having a menacing face it's something
to hear do you are you're doing it now
you were staring at me I thought a bowl
but do you find that - because you've
played so many different kinds of roles
but is it fun to play bad I would think
it might be yeah I like it I grew up
around those guys you know I was a grew
up in New York right at the border
Greenwich Village in Little Italy so a
lot of my friends were sons or daughters
of mafioso or wannabes and so I kind of
knew this guy when I was a kid this this
kind of town Don you know that the guy
that can get stuff for you and the guy
you don't want to cross there was this
guy named happy that lived across the
street from us and everyone knew never
to mess with Happy's kids even though
they were you know totally mess about
mess with a bull yeah is that a word
sure for you anything so anyway we would
never mess with Happy's kids and so I
always was curious about that that kind
of that planned that kind of guy and
this opportunity came up and yeah I like
the I like playing that it's easy to do
particularly in the morning when you're
kind of a little grumpy anyway you know
it's really hard to do what you do be
funny you know it's it's much more
exhausting
I mean in a game of averages I'm sure it
was funny man I'm like yeah sometimes
but it's a lot more effort to be funny
than it is to be grumpy yeah so I I had
such a great cast to work with Lizzy
Caplan is a genius
I love litigants oh goodness Castle Rock
she plays Kathy Bates remember that
movie misery what I love is these are
all hooked into sort of the Stephen King
you know world yeah you know which is
what I love is they pick up on
characters so in misery this is the
prequel to misery so you'll understand
now why Kathy Bates was psyched so
psychotic we see her at a much younger
age
yeah yeah and and you encounter her well
this is I think we have a clip here okay
I don't know if we need to know much I
think you're talking to is this you
talking to your son yes yes yes season
two all right let's take a look at this
clip from Castle Rock two more tenants
leaving me early for a half D small
leaving you that's a good mystery who's
one will leave you you could put an end
to this [ __ ] could I have Duncan land
Abdi got for a song and had job that was
eminent domain one call State Board no
new mall you could have stuck you
getting into this whole thing that way
you want me sticking my thought you
wanted to be in charge you just served
me up to him in the race Jesus Christ
pop you gotta tell AB you cut this [ __ ]
out we're gonna lose everything
no the mall your house everything you
have I gave you [ __ ] I took what I
deserve
remember sergeant major
you'd be wise not to bring that up again
that's the power of a real actor like
you you read that line or you say that
line and I would not bring that up again
you know just dinner to me if you said
you'd be wise that I would not bring it
up again if I had that role I'd be like
they would bring it right back up again